I want to shift gears a little bit and
talk about xbox one and Phil Spencer
said you will actually see us come out
with a new hardware capabilities during
this generation at an investor call a
couple of months ago this has been
something that he's sort of like touched
on a couple of pieces during a
generation during a generation not this
generous generation so do you think that
the xbox one being the console of the
two that most people would say is
probably requiring an upgrade do you
think that they'll go with similar route
I think that they certainly could and
let's see why they wouldn't especially
because they exist in the PC space where
this is something that the pretty used
to run yes and look both both of the
GPUs in each of the consoles are created
by AMD their manufacturing processes in
terms of how small and and cool they can
make chips right have improved quite a
bit I believe both consoles started at
28 nanometers and now they're down to
like 14 nanometer manufacturing
processes so the same hardware developer
working with both you know partners I
mean it stands to reason that they will
approach Microsoft if sony has
approached them or they've approached
sony it just seems to make sense to me I
don't see why they wouldn't the other
thing about this is i guess is that
they're sort of unified the windows
platform as well are listed that's the
direction they've been going in
frustration and the Xbox originally was
always this big plan to try and get the
pc space in the living room to to own
that space which it seems really weird
that in 2016 we still don't have a real
leader there in fact it's kind of broken
into all these other things like steam
machines and you know for a while there
is house shuttle pcs might be how it all
goes do eventually do we start to see
the walls break down then between
because if the xbox one essentially
becomes a upgradable console then it's
almost only different 2 pc in branding
at that site oh no now services my
friend services like wow pc gamers don't
need xbox live oh yeah good point I mean
you're gonna if those two really become
unified Microsoft will have to back off
some of their their practices to make
money off of consoles which are
traditionally sold really close to cost
or under cost so unless they do that I
don't I don't think they could bring
both markets together and make both
party
happy but maybe that's maybe they're
trying to offset that but what they're
doing with quantum break with the whole
you can repurchase this via the Windows
Store they're trying to like take some
self-control is the same with gears of
war 10 I mean yeah there might be part
of that but that's no one's happy about
that I think if anything that's going to
turn people off yeah I mean you look at
something like that and you immediately
say but steam does it this you know like
there's already a better example out
there than what they're trying to do on
PC and just like games for windows live
I can't see this effort lasting long
enough to actually lead to any
meaningful positive change for Microsoft
it's only going to be a detriment over
time Mike doing on xbox one yep would
you be looking forward to an upgraded
version of it or I mean if the
PlayStation 4 ends up getting its
getting a GPU push then what does that
even the xbox one the graphical part
here is it gonna be real fun man right
yeah I don't know I yeah I would be you
know up for it I've never there are a
few games I've noticed you know like
most of time when I choose between ps4
and xbox one and I go ps4 just because
the majority of my friends i play with
or on that it's not always a graphical
you no consideration but I have to
imagine if Microsoft was thinking about
doing something this generation not that
that's what they said the whole
PlayStation 4.5 might be kind of the
impetus for them to consider it even
more strongly hmm yeah i'd be up for it
I don't know that I would be you know
jumping at the gun to get it right away
the only because like I said I'd like
quantum break looks great on the xbox
one I think we're playing like rise of
the Tomb Raider DLC later I've never had
I have never had like a situation where
i said i really wish i was playing us on
ps4 just because it would look that much
better right you know in that case i
would probably just go to pc if I did
it's that much of an upgrade I had a bit
of that over the witcher because i
thought because i saw people playing on
playstation 4 and i was playing on the
xbox one and it actually did like i
could notice that there was the sharper
looking on the playstation 4 of course
I'm pc like I could even look at the pc
version right sounds like disgusting to
me I have a wild theory okay go for it
both companies are potentially planning
this because the Nintendo NX will be
more powerful than the current
iterations ah no I'm not gonna be crazy
no I like dude that's that's one hundred
percent of possibility yeah yeah thanks
I a counterpunch to Nintendo's
wing yeah what I mean I mean if it ok
man with the most powerful console in
the world I'll be quite a statement yes
yeah so all right that's all I just know
I just want to throw that out there
because I honestly people have there
have been rumors that they are working
towards a device that is the most
powerful and if that's true these
companies have to do it could we be
looking at an e3 where we see three
consoles us oh I hope so that would be
so much fun I want a wild and crazy III
so bad and I don't want it to be just
about VR I really wanted to be just
about VR well GDC was maybe a bit too
much on the VR yeah I'd I'm obviously
that's not like so a CEO has two years
yeah anyway we'll have to see
interesting times I have talked about
history already have far away from me
three two months two months and change
march april may june three months three
months three new console kobe coming i
let us know what you're excited for is
it the playstation 4.5 the xbox one
point five they're not gonna call it a
point five isn't that screws them up if
they need to put out another iteration
three years Oh point six well what
happened to point to one through but I
color the 4.2 4.1 the 4k and then they
say what doesn't do for okay then it's
gonna be no new 4k video Oh God and they
call it the xbox too haha yeah why not
the xbox three two if you're talking
about like cleat like you know Xbox to
blending the identity of what Microsoft
gaming is then Xbox to is just as good
as anything else that can come on if
they call it xbox to that's the worst
thing in the world that's awful the
fourth Xbox is the xbox should we make a
bet if this comes out whether it's
called that or not okay yeah what's the
bet dr. shave my beard again oh but I
like your beard okay when you shave your
beard and I'll shave my head for a
five-hundred-dollar dinner wait wait
wait I want to shave something why can I
the body parts like a poodle l they did
by the poodle anyway okay i don't have
three way back complicates things okay
I'm washing my hands all you too okay
you shave your beard I'll shave my head
ok if it's called Xbox to you should be
rude no no no you shave your head I'll
shave my head yeah and if it's not
you'll shave your your bid Phil Spencer
you're reading
I this is the sort of bed that I'd like
to make okay yeah looking forward to it
Phil Spencer if you're watching I've got
a whole I'll come up with an XL
spreadsheet better names than xbox to
take your pick if you're watching this
on demand please put your thoughts in
the comments would you like an Xbox to
PlayStation 4.5 and what other
alternative names would be better xbox
on the Xbox y'all got they would call it
up they would totally calling it would
you play baked into it Oh cart down from
the comments below